foreign
[Music]
I can't even see around that bend
because this whole place is just thick
with
every boss you can imagine
I get this sense that it's so easy to
get lost here
I'm in Gabon the most forested country
in all of Africa
nearly 90 of it is just like this
rainforest
it's such an unfamiliar environment to
me and yeah I feel like I'm
at the mercy of everything around me
definitely tell you now that I am well
outside my comfort zone
that's how I like to do things learn by
doing
I've given myself seven days to make it
deep in the gabonese jungle
I want to learn all I can about this
mysterious place and survive the
experience
it's smooth now but it can get nasty on
rapid
gosh it's getting loud
it's making me nervous
I can't seem very far Downstream
especially when it's a river that you
don't know
this spree
that's not rapid
I can't see the river that's the
waterfall
get off the water get off the water
power power power power power
I want to stay to that side
a power through ah whoa whoa that's a
drop that's a drop
ped it
push out push out
I'm Dwayne Fields Explorer and
adventurer
in the wilderness is Where I Come Alive
oh Viper it's my true calling whoa in
2010 I became the first black British
man to Trek to the North Pole
progress is that way
I love to push myself to the Limit well
drop now I'm challenging myself to
survive a week in some of the harshest
environments on earth
oh man this is going to be intense
using all my skill determination and
will to survive
here we go
that's why I'm here in the rainforest of
Gabon
this is gonna be my seven toughest days
I knew there's a waterfall coming but I
did not expect it so quickly
back on dry ground is where the real
struggle begins
the Japanese jungle is unlike any
extreme environment I've ever faced
in preparation for my challenge I met
Jungle Guide juice Lane who's given me a
few pointers that may help me survive on
my mission
are there any roads any footpaths any
what there are no roads uh but there
will be definitely elephant trails
this area isn't very well mapped is it
no it's remote it's it's Forest It's a
Jungle it's tropical forest so it's
going to be tough
it's hard to navigate any distance in
the Deep canopy with no obvious
landmarks why did you come here I just
can't learn things from a book man but
just Lane mentioned there's an elaborate
underground cave system to the South
which I hope to find
my plan is to meet up with Jesus Lane in
seven days at a remote airstrip
with so little information to go on I
have no idea what lies in between
what nearly ended me
[Music]
massive whoa
that looks like it's about 180 feet
and literally just come out just up
there I can hear it I can see all the
spray
couldn't see it
there's a ledge here but even that looks
terrible the water's just flooding off
of this hitting there there's no way I
can get down here I'm gonna have to go
Downstream
some tall trees there probably use one
of those as an anchor
make my way down to the base of this
waterfall see if I can find a way back
onto the water down there
up here not gonna happen
sling around this that's not going
anywhere
climbed before
I've used ropes before
not with this much water
can't even tell if it's red or if it's
spray the noise
the spray absolutely Epic
that's my umbilical
oh
there we go
the water's blood it's hot in my eyes
should have brought goggles
I've never been so wet and not being
fully subversed
it's raining up it's raining down it's
coming from the side
ah every single thing is soaking wet
noise is deafening
awesome
I'm gonna head Downstream and try and
get down past these Rapids see if I can
get back on the water
as much as I can hear the waterfall I
can feel it when you touch the Rocks you
can feel it shaking vibrating them
huge amount of power
in the peak of the rainy season it's
estimated these
these thousand tons of water every
second
that's like 900 small cars slamming down
this section of the river every second
I do not want to go in there
Gabon gets up to 11 feet of rainfall
each year and swollen Rivers May
kayaking a dangerous option I'm here at
the end of the wet season
Rapids and waterfalls are big hazards
out here
working through this dense jungle is
really tough along with crocodiles Gabon
has 30 species of venomous snake and
nearly a hundred thousand Forest
elephants
thick impenetrable growth makes any
encounter with them potentially
dangerous
I may not know how close they are until
it's too late
ah
this tree is massive
ah good
see this resin
I reckon
if this is the yakumi tree
it should light
this akume resin's got flammable Earls
making it a great fire star
come on come on
this is awesome
smell that I'm almost guaranteed fire
tonight
also the smoke it keeps mosquitoes and
other insects away all right enough of
that let me find something to wrap this
in keep it safe
it's a really good find a really really
good find
what was that
something just slithered down underneath
that log
could be a crocodile it could be a snake
could be a frog
[Music]
the thing you just don't know in here
that direction Southeast following the
river down there is going to take me of
course and I'm losing daylight quickly
I'm gonna Wade across
I have to do it before it gets dark
I know there's crocodile
there's nightfalls they come out they
get in the water they start hunting
I'm gonna do it now
and take my pack off if it suddenly gets
deep I can use this to float
it's a borrow
there's a crocodile that owns it there's
more boroughs all the way along they
could belong to dwarf crocodiles which
aren't known to be dangerous but there
are three species of crocking caban
including the Nile crocodile
narcross can grow up to 20 feet long and
are known to eat pretty much anything
that moves
their dangerous stealthy predators and
I've heard there are up to 200 deaths a
year in Africa from Nile croc attacks
it might just sucks your feet down
[Music]
creepiest thing I've ever done
whoa there we go now it's getting deeper
oh
it's hard to tell if you're brushing
something or if it's brushing you
whoa
they're just bubbles just coming up to
the surface it makes you wonder what's
under there
oh
something's in here
foreign
there
good I'm out of that
I've only got about an hour of daylight
left so I'll be hard-pressed to get back
to the river by Nightfall let's get into
that stage of the day now
where I'm looking for a place to camp
that's not too bad is it
ah this is good
ants look at that that's why I chose a
hammock
yeah that's going far
some ants all here oh that's got ants
flooding out of it ants and and and just
carries on oh look there's a mess of
them
oh they find their way in
ants are the most abundant insects on
Earth
20 quadrillion of them
that's a 20 with 15 zeros after it
there's 383 species of antsync upon
feels like right now they're all here
something on my mind showed me
Menthol rub on the cords between where
you're sleeping and the tree
that way no creepy crawlies
will get to you they hate this stuff
the other one
squash balls down one side
[Music]
ah
this is like a dream
[Music]
all right shelter done
firewood
everything's soaked
if I can't find dry wood make dry wood
I've just got to cut the outer parts to
get to the dry core inside
that's going to be really easy to light
fire is essential out here
for safety at night not just comfort
it'll discourage any curious Critters
from getting too close
hopefully enough for the PS to
resistance
so glad I found this akume resin
see if this works
don't play games with me
come on
oh
yes
yes I'm in the middle of a rainforest
and I have fire
Morale on 100 right now
it's so weird that a fire right here in
the middle of a rainforest ingubon can
remind me of me being a kid in Jamaica
thousands of miles away
but it does
it reminds me of Bill's number fire just
like this one
and I'd roast cashew nuts on it
[Music]
Dwayne Fields you bad boy
you made fire in a deep dark jungle I'm
excited it's going pretty well
I think
five six-year-old Dwayne Fields would be
mad proud right now
but I'm winning
all right Dwayne
get to work
didn't have any mosquitoes I didn't have
any ants so
top tip
use Menthol rub
it's day two and I've barely made a dent
in this wall of jungle there's a lot of
green between me and those caves I'm
looking for
ah
that's a snake I think it's a bush viper
look how well camouflaged it is Bush
vipers Ambush their prey and then strike
within milliseconds the Venom can be
fatal and we're a long way from help I
could have passed 50 on the way up here
it's one thing knowing that they're here
but
until you see one I don't know it just
clicked something in your head in your
mind you just oh gosh every single thing
looks like a snake now
makes my skin crawl
this is so thick
ah this is painful
it's just these that take it out my legs
jungle is tough
there's Rooks there's pitfalls
and not to mention every single thing
has a spine on it
everything in here to start to get me it
feels like
I had enough of this jungle forcing you
to change direction
I'll never make it to the airstrip if I
have to keep fighting Through the Jungle
like this
I'm gonna have to come with a different
plan I've barely covered any ground
the river will be faster
I need to jump back on the water it's a
lot calmer Now cover a lot more ground
Before Sunset and hopefully find a spot
to camp while they're still like
back into the unknown
I won't make it to the caves tonight
I've burnt up too much time I need to
find a spot to make Camp we've probably
got an hour or so sunlight
there's this weird Haze like a Mist
which is coming off all the trees the
proper Mystic looking
as you lose the light you start
listening more because you can't use
your eyes as much
it's like a whole list of animals that
coming alive now
I can hear frogs or birds or insects
over there because they all sound the
same when you can't see them
what was that
this Inlet the tree's thin a little bit
this is creepy
that is hard ground I think I lucked out
make sure there's nothing
little crocodiles or anything in here
tree tree
that's my hammock sorted
that's dry wood this is good
just in time
different world
I've never been to a jungle like this
it reminds me when I lived in London and
feeling like I didn't belong living
basically a lie
that sense of not fitting in not finding
a place in the world
and it led me down a path where
I lost myself
I would like to think that I will make
it through this challenge
if I do I will have somehow
gone back to my roots after leaving them
for so long
on this map the airstrip isn't that far
away
well in a straight line anyway
the rivers don't take me where I need to
go so I'm going to cut my way through
the bush
which I don't really want to do
jeslane told me about a cave system that
could get me out of this Green Hill for
a while trouble is this area isn't very
well mapped
which means I don't know exactly how to
get there but I know I need to head
south
foreign
this jungle is full of so many
challenges as I get further in the heat
is really taking its toll on me
we're so close to the equator and I'm
feeling it
it's time of year the temperature really
drops below 79 degrees Fahrenheit
[Music]
that could be people
chiselaine said there are people living
in this jungle
he said if I come across people give out
a call
feel a bit nervous about that actually
why calling I'm telling them I'm here
and I don't mean them any harm that I'm
not a poacher
I want him to know I haven't come to
take anything from them
I'm not trying to sneak across their
property across their land
that's a woman's voice
I can hear children as well it could be
the backer semi-nomadic hunter-gatherers
they've been living here for about 400
centuries that's 80 times older than the
ancient Egyptians
[Music]
singing
I'm trying to get a whoop back so I feel
like safe going and I don't want to walk
into working times
Village or
Campo
that was a woot back
whoo
my whooped I don't know what to do now
because Jizzle never told me what to do
if they were back
uh
bonjour
so this is the awkward part I genuinely
don't know what to do now
um
more French francaise very petite yeah
oh good what do I remember from French
in school
um uh jumia Bell Dwayne
I'm
long distance grand
um grand grand kilometer Grand Voyage
Grand Voyage
I'm hungry hungry
see
hey
yeah
down this way
show me okay
I don't have a clue what's happening the
kids are telling me to go that way
[Music]
step step there
I'm literally just following
instructions now
[Music]
and they've blocked it here
okay
ah they're trying to get me fish
on Fish I've never seen anything like
this
do you want me to do it take it out
they're trying to show me something so
I'm just I don't think I'm just doing
what they say
[Music]
oh yeah
this guy's doing something he's put his
hand in a hole in the in the mud I've
never ever in my life seen fishing like
this before it's just so labor intensive
you've got fish uh
so it's fish that lives in the mud
yeah
uh there's more fish
oh very good that's three more fish
we go and eat
[Music]
we gonna cook some fish
oh that's a bigger
they're wrapping the fish in Miranda say
leaves it's a good way to cook in the
forest and it keeps the flavor
and told the back of people can survive
on this meager meal in dire times two
fish is enough to sustain one person
depending on the size when fishing's
really good 30 to 50 fish can feed a
whole family
I could flow with the forest
when they're here they set up temporary
camps following food sources they go
where the plants and animals are
touched that they've so quickly embraced
me into their way of life
[Music]
it's humbling for me to see how the
backers seemed to live so harmoniously
with the environment I feel like I can
learn so much from them but I can't stay
around I need to get to the caves and
maybe they can help me I don't know how
to say this walk
into get into cave yeah yeah grunt
um
that way
I'm not entirely sure but it sounds like
it's in that direction which is very
good
just want to enjoy this fight a little
bit more enjoy the company and then
maybe make my excuses and hit the road
[Music]
thank you
and my mind
I need to start thinking about making a
come for the night
I think that's an elephant print
it's hard to tell
there's an estimated hundred thousand
Forest elephants that call Gabon home
right now at the end of the wet season
they're migrating from the protection of
the Jungle back out to the swampy
lowlands that's a lot of elephant
traffic
I'm just looking for a decent sized tree
with enough branches
that I can climb up or get up there and
Nest there for the night because I'm not
sleeping on the ground
that's not too bad
I'm going to take my chances with this
I can't imagine it's going to be
comfortable but at least I'll be off the
ground
wait
so I'm gonna use these tie my cord to a
couple of these it's way enough I'm
hopeful
see how good my aim is
just through that one set right there
straight through the middle
pull it up
oh
ah yes perfect
so now I can time my rope to this end
pull it up and get myself up the tree
nice and safe for the night
oh yes
look at that
on a day like today when I'm this tired
this is not the easiest thing to do
when I've got a heavy pack on my back
and I've been making my way through this
jungle all day
tired I'm sweaty
I can see some light through the trees
now as well
and for the first time since getting
into this jungle
I actually feel safe
I never imagined I'd ever be in a deep
dark jungle sleeping in a tree I feel
like I'm supposed to be beating my chest
or something like get my whole Tarzan
Vibe going on
I'll try and get some sleep safer than
knowledge that I'm not going to bump
into any three-ton elephant in the dark
this place never sleeps
I haven't slept the wig
every single frog
every single Cricket every bird they
just never stop and it feels like
they're all either in this tree or
around this tree and I'm on the show and
they're the audience
just listen to this
you're not sleep deprivation is the
worst thing
when you add that to the fact that I
feel like the slightest movement I'm
gonna fall I'm really regretting coming
up here
there's something in the bushes just
down there
can't see a damn thing out here
black
I think I'm in its backyard and it
decided he didn't want me here
foreign
there was something down there last
night I know it
I don't know if it's me or if this
jungle is getting thicker by the day I
swear it's getting thicker every single
day it feels like I'm working harder
than the day before
I'm gonna check out see if I can see any
tracks find out what was down here last
night
[Music]
look at this
I knew it
that's an elephant print I can't mistake
that that's what an elephant print looks
like round toe toe toe toe
definitely down here
this is a path
only an elephant would make a path like
this it has to be something big
that's what they do they're known as the
ecologists or the forest whatever they
eat they walk around they leave the
seeds they're basically creating the
forest and the trails as they go
once an elephant clears a bit of
a bit of a path other animals start to
use it
and that's when it becomes like a proper
visible visible Trail
that's an elephant that's an elephant
this is an elephant here look at the
size of that foot this thing must be
massive
my heart's pounding
I'm like a weird mix of excited and
anxious
an elephant could be 20 feet from me and
I wouldn't even know it it's so thick in
here
but that's the direction the trail goes
in
because Lane said there's a waterfall at
the entrance to the cave if this Trail
was made by elephants searching for
water I may be in luck
[Music]
it's my final day here in Gabon
if I can find the caves and get through
I'll have one more challenge left
get into the airstrip
foreign
I can see it
looks like a big waterfall as well
whoa
I think that's the cave
which is Lane said this Cavern is about
a mile long and a single track it'll be
nice to get out of the jungle
let's have a look
thank you
this is flowing water if it can get out
I can too
which means I can
follow this no more hacking
no more jungle or strolling down a river
underneath the jungle Gabon has some of
the oldest cave systems on the planet
for millions of years water has been
carving out the underground highways
into this bedrock
flash floods are a real present threat
but
whoa there's thousands of them
not a massive fan of bats to be honest
just reminds me of some old vampire
movie
oh oh gosh that's bat poo ah it's moving
uh all these little white dots just bugs
crawling
not touching that their feces are called
back guano don't want to breathe this
stuff in there could be fungus spores in
the air from it which can cause
histoplasmosis an infection of the lungs
oh this is gross it's all good I love
they're all waking up now
please don't poo on me
thought playing in my mind
all of this
damp area of rock that was the water
level recently
if it rains up top down here we'll fill
up
and it could fill up fast
I need to get out
this is the entire
ah some petite
what's down there
I can't get out there
I really hope I don't get stuck turning
back now would not be good
that's opening up
I've got another water
covering a lot of
a lot of ground
well a lot of underground
you could be anything in this water
you just don't know what's down here
oh
snake oh Viper
that can kill
it's a Viper I can tell from the
arrowhead shape on his head I think
that's a rhinoceros Viper
the Venom in that destroys tissue
if it bites me that can kill
I'm Moving Straight on
they can swim and they can swim fast
Upstream as well
I am not claustrophobic but this is
this is starting to do something to me
I need to get out of this cave
it's just endless Darkness
that's light
come on
that's daylight
ah look at this trees
haha
ah I'm out
whoa this is like
it's like a lost world
[Music]
never been so happy to see daylight and
trees
oh
that means it's back to bushwacking
[Music]
just seen that vine I missed pioneer
it's made me think of something
when you get a good green one this is
still alive
thick like this we might be lucky enough
to find fresh water
ah oh yes
it's fresh it's good to drink
that tastes like life
the woods like a natural filter the
pores in the vine are small enough to
filter out bacteria the water's clear
not milky no smells oh no hot
humid day in the jungle
that
is as good as if not better than a can
of Coke
so desperate to get out here this is the
biggest it's been so far
ah it's getting lighter come on
that's light
hang on this has to be this is the
airstrip
how do we get that
ah
it's the airstrip
she's lame
you made it
how are you doing
you'll never believe what's just
happened over the last week
oh it's so good to see you yeah me too
did you find a waterfall did I find the
waterfall that found me oh really yeah I
nearly went over ah man I'm so tired
I cannot believe it I survived seven
days in one of the wettest and densest
rainforests I've ever heard of
and I learned some valuable lessons from
gabon's rivers and nomadic people
that no matter what I do I can't fight
nature I need to flow with it
I feel rooted and The Roots here they
run deep
that's why I do this connecting with
nature to connect with myself
[Music]
thank you